escaping the pandemic
desperate migrants forced their way
across security lines on an
international amazon bridge
the group is mainly made up of haitians
as well as africans
some are pregnant or with children and
are carrying what little they have
but the border is closed and on
wednesday police and the military
stopped them and sent them back
in the morning there were more than 300
they pushed the police and ran to the
peruvian side
but then the police partly pushed them
back here with violence which should not
be allowed to happen
[Applause]
the caravan has been stranded on the
border region of madrid
since friday they set up tents waiting
for a chance to make their way north
officials say to haiti panama or the u.s
they just want to get to their land
looking for a better life here they're
left waiting for days in the middle of
the bridge
in the rain small children get wet it's
a desperate situation
some among the most vulnerable were
allowed to stay on pedu's side
some tested positive for coronavirus
there's only one doctor says the mayor
and no infrastructure to take care of
them
we have a dengue epidemic no health
services the clinic is a small tent
the rains are difficult even for the
police and soldiers it is very difficult
to tend to them in this situation
unhcr officials say the migrants are
fleeing strict lockdowns
a lack of jobs and the virus raging in
brazil
and the solution for any government is
not easy
the people want to continue but the
northern borders are closed
and it's difficult to ask authorities to
be flexible the healthcare in peru has
absolutely collapsed
if they get sick there are no hospital
beds and allowing them to continue is
taking the problem from one place to the
next
pedus borders have been closed for
months in january
authorities sent tanks to guard the
poorest northern border to stop
venezuelan migrants from crossing from
ecuador
peru usually has an open arms policy for
migrants
now local authorities say the foreign
ministries of peru and brazil
should find a quick solution because
those migrants are already living in
dire condition
and there are so many more desperate the
caravan
is likely to grow for now the mayor on
both sides of the bridge and a catholic
organization
are giving these migrants some food and
water but despite the hurdles they're
stationed on the bridge
waiting for the next chance to get
lima
across